FREDDIE ANDERSON.
WE ARE ON THE WAY IN RALEIGH.
JUST A LITTLE SNAPSHOT MAKE
SURE YOU GET THROUGH.
>> John: SABINE NEDELJKOVIC.
ANOTHER SABINE
COMES IN BUT YOU GOTTA LOVE HOW
-- TROCHECK TO -- A ON GOAL SO
>> Ryan: NEDELJKOVIC IS58PLAY
TO THE SPIRIT.
SO GOOD AT STANDING UP AND
CAUSING THOSE TURNOVERS.
BAND.
GLOVE
COUPLE OF GOOD OPPORTUNITIES
HERE IN FRONT OF
THEIR AGAIN.
TRIES TO BRING IT TO HIS FOUR J
IN.
FOR THE THEN AT A TRIES
TO GO
BACK AND THERE.
EXCELLENT PASSER TROCHECK.
2 ONHE OFFENSIVE
GOAL.
BREAKOUT, --
AHO.
BACK TO THE POINT HE COMES TO
D'ANGELO.
SNYDER.
WHAT IS
-- COMES UP IT.
IN?
NO.
IT
THE GAME'S FIRST GOAL.
AND THEY ARE PERPLEXED.
>> Ryan: TO FORMER TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING.
TRY TO
THROUGH.
LITTLE DROP PASS.
-- GOES
AHO.
FIRES.
NEDELJKOVIC. THIS LEAGUE.
>> Ryan: ESPECIALLY AGAINST A
TEAM LIKE THIS WHEN AHO IS
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
>>
>> John: AHO GETS
SCORE.
PAM. 0. DETROIT
CAROLINA THREATENING.
-- GOES CRAZY --.
TO KEON BOTH
TEAMS.
THERE IS SKJEI.
MY SHAKE AND BAKE. TWISTED MR..
10th OF THE YEAR FOR THE 22-
YEAR-OLD CHECK BACK AND DETROIT
LOOKING GOOD  BRINGS THAT THING
YOU CAN SEE -- A LITTLE BIT OF
A KNUCKLE PUCK. -- DON'T THINK
MATTERS. CHANCE.
SVECHNIKOV IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY.
BU
BEER HAS IT.
HE DOES IT OFF